les groupes pour l'intervention selon
après la tentative d'assassinât sion
jacques chirac les gendarmes
s'intéressent de plus en plus au site
néo nazis sur internet
maxi monnerie on le sait communiquer via
ce réseau
sophie guillemin hélène frade ont suivi
le travail d'une cellule de la
gendarmerie qui surveille le net
aujourd'hui et vous allez le voir le
travail est immense
leur journée de travail il la passe à
surfer sur internet
ces gendarmes qui font partie du centre
de lutte contre la délinquance de haute
technologie sont chargés de surveiller
le réseau à 8 il traque les infractions
commises par les internautes
nos recherches portent principalement
sur tout ce qui touche aux escroqueries
par carte bancaire aux contrefaçons de
logiciels commerciaux à la
pédocriminalité faut aussi à la
diffusion à la propagande de messages
révisionniste ou vous à nos fans la
plupart du temps les gendarmes
travaillent sur requête de leurs
collègues à travers la france ici par
exemple une brigade du sud leur demande
des renseignements sur un site pédophile
en visionnant le site ans on essaie de
vérifier son contenu ont par la suite on
vérifie également si celui-ci hébergé en
france et ses ressortissants français
est impliqué il habite ce site si le
site est effectivement hébergé en france
l' enquête va pouvoir se dérouler si ce
n'est pas le cas il faudra alerté
interpol et là les choses se compliquent
car certains pays refusent de collaborer
autre obstacle les différentes
législations qui existent sur la planète
la propagande néo nazis par exemple est
autorisée dans certains pays au nom de
la liberté d'expression en france elle
est interdite
les gendarmes essaye donc de repérer
ceux qui s'y livrent aidé par la plupart
des fournisseurs d'accès chais skalli
par exemple salariés et bénévoles
observent à la loupe les pages
personnelles des internautes
mais regardons de façon très rigoureuse
le contenu les différentes consoles cash
et eiffage personnel afin d'identifier
les contenus des sites qui pourraient
s'y trouver
dès qu'il s'agit de pédophilie ou de
racisme avéré nous prenons même la
décision d'aller voir les services de
police pour leur fournir ces
renseignements pour tester l'efficacité
de ces contrôles
nous avons cassé ce matin cette annonce
provocatrice deux heures après elle
était toujours là
preuve qu'avec des millions
d'informations qui s'échangent chaque
jour le net est décidément bien
difficile à contrôler